reid hoffman is one of Silicon Valley's
most high-profile investors he was an
early investor in Facebook and again as
a co-founder of linkedin hoffman is also
a partner at the venture capital firm
Greylock he co-authored a new book
called blitzscaling the lightning fast
path to building massively valuable
companies he interviewed hundreds of
entrepreneurs from companies like
Facebook Netflix and Airbnb Hoffman says
blitzscaling is prioritizing speed over
efficiency when developing a company he
joins us first on CBS this morning yeah
welcome great to be here if you're
building a car you don't want speed over
efficiency because the wheels will roll
off so why is speed important for what
you're talking about
well there actually are cars that
prioritize speed over efficiency so now
gas mileage everything else not look
wheels falling off the reason why you
want this is this is the modern way that
you build massive companies if you look
at Airbnb if you look at Hoover if you
look at a lot of these companies that 10
years ago were were ideas back of
napkins in tiny and now our global
transformational companies this is the
set of techniques that we've learned in
Silicon Valley in order to do that and
we would like to spread those techniques
to as many places as possible
you said the team may make you feel
uncomfortable doing it you drew you
taught you to quote drew Houston from
Dropbox who says it's like harpooning a
whale it's a good thing and it's also a
bad thing but you highly recommend it
despite the prep the pratfalls and
pitfalls that come with it well because
if you build these companies then you
build the companies that actually
transform the world and we're now in
this place where what we call Glengarry
Glen Ross markets which is first place
Cadillac second price steak knives third
knives or five you know third prize you
fired yeah and so it really matters to
establish these companies on a global
footprint as fast as possible and that
those are the techniques that make it
possible first mover's advantage so let
me ask you this though some companies
that I've talked to small startups that
have a great idea they're worried if
they get too much too big too fast
they'll just spread out and and and
they'll lose it they'll just be a mess
because they can't keep track of getting
bigger well sometimes the biggest risk
is not taking risks here and so you have
to take those risks the scale it's scary
it's uncertain you actually in fact can
blow up and you can make mistakes
but only by playing that speed the scale
is the only way that you can
yeah yeah one of the concepts of
blitzscaling is embracing chaos when you
look at companies that have evolved from
being one thing to another like Twitter
like Facebook
what is how does chaos help them it's
easy to look in hindsight and say well
they should have changed strategies but
how do you know when that inflection
point happens so roughly speaking you're
looking at kind of when does the when
have you gotten to the kind of global
position that you've gotten to the fact
that you're now shifting more to
efficiency and the reason why you have
to embrace chaos is because you're
growing so fast you're changing your
management you're changing what's going
on in your product you have to
understand that you're not gonna it's
not gonna have this comfortable and
efficiency where you learn it and just
iterate slowly you're gonna be doing
massive changes every 6 to 12 months
including in how you run the company and
so by embracing chaos and knowing that
we are gonna be kind of running in a way
that looks totally chaotic what we're
doing though in order to get to be the
first to scale is the way that you
actually succeed following up on Lazarus
Point because these are counterintuitive
things embrace chaos ignore your
customer you say what because the
customer is always right but this this
got to me launch a product that
embarrasses you does it mean read so
what company wants to do that well
LinkedIn did it I mean we have it so
there's a lot of companies that have
done this new coke the entire classic
plan but essentially it begins your
future customers are the ones that
matter and that if you you need to be
able to get your product to market and
be learning from your customers and
learning how to iterate it and so the
launching of product embarrass you
obviously embarrassment is not something
you yeah deeply desire but it's a way of
prioritizing speed of getting to
engaging with your customer learning
from them and being the first that's in
that learning curve in terms of getting
the scale so again it's basically taking
down the usual barriers to risk taking
right so people are worried about
failing the word they're gonna upset
their customers they're worried that
people are gonna be unhappy in the
workplace your argument is forget about
all that you want to keep taking risks
because risks make you bigger faster yes
and you and Elon were together on PayPal
should we be worried about Elon I was
worried well look Ilan's a national
treasure right
Tesla SpaceX except I wouldn't bet
against him now and obviously you know
it's a pretty stressful circumstance
right now but we should all be rooting
for him yes here here blitzscaling is
the name of the book you and your co
Arthur Chris who's in the green room we
should get a shot of Chris who's here
today - this book is for anyone who
wants to understand techniques that
allow business to grow from zero to a
multi-billion dollar market leader who
doesn't want that rain Chris there you
go blitzscaling is on sale tomorrow
wherever you like to buy your books